if it's against the world of survival
I should happen so the last time but
also you got a lot done I mean I can do
better but I didn't not everything bad
happen like I got this manhole opener
you know I wasn't total wash nah just
cuz I died a couple dogs I am on caution
hungry but I got some mixed herbs yeah
so you want me to open up that manhole
is that yeah there's a couple you can go
through one in the kennel one down the
dog hallway
so now I need the map already
so how do you feel oh I think you could
check the helicopter for an item if I'm
not memory serves the helicopters like
behind you I know I feel are you asking
me how I feel yeah just like in life oh
not that great I was kidding
is it the helicopter behind it or
something hmm I'm sorry to the left of
it maybe not all right anyway I'm so
injured all right woman going the other
side over here take it on the other side
I'm Gerry singie today totally in I
always am um this rooms always so
ominous
oh damn crows good yeah
I just wanna make sure that guy was
still there
found some herbs in here last time they
saved my life yeah you're in bad shape
yeah I was doing really bad last time I
was on like critical danger like can't
can't even take a little touch from a
zombie yep
oh right where am I going we need to
talk about this play map up i meanyou're
am I going in that hallway up so I'm not
going into the danger zone right nice
see you later losers
sugar more sugar
hey I remember all this did I kill all
the dogs I think I did because I'm
telling you right now I mean not in the
kennel or that no oh wait go do the
power thing actually what do you mean no
no you're got no you got to keep coming
remember that math power puzzle yes I do
remember that yeah now we should read
the directions this time back this way
but yeah it oh it is you're right you're
right it's like the first one on the
right or something this is the power
room we didn't read the directions and
you were like I can't remember if you
win when you get to 80 or if it explodes
either way something funny's mad
exciting it's important to make that
distinction let's find out power can be
routed to the areas with insufficient
power using these five switches using
all the power make calls as short and
cut the power supply it's ah I didn't
even [ __ ] tell me yes I'm saying I
think we should just go past 80 no don't
go past it try to land on it it's that's
why it's red so oh wait doesn't make
sense
so this is just a math thing right 36:14
3614 I don't know just the 36 for now
can you do negative no no wait if you
went down now then you might be able to
get to the maths that you couldn't have
before
well we what are we kind of gotten 80
last time we just didn't because we
weren't sure there's a blind spot for me
let's figure it out
all right 36 I say up well if you go up
again millio at 78
yeah that's math 72 I would say go down
there at 22 okay so another 36 would be
58 yep and then good 44 if you go down
and then up it'll hit 80 try that out
sit down up I don't think that you have
really actually worked this out
mathematically yeah you just we yeah we
winged that all right we're good power
supply okay sweet now you go through
their door next all right let's do that
I think it's just the kennel room isn't
it no we already went through the kennel
yeah you can go through the kennel
without the power supply because I did
remember and I heard little
pitter-patter there's a little puppies
feets and I ran away I think it's one
right next to you right here I think
it's to the right yeah it's this one you
might have to hit that key card thing
first okay I'm not
nope oh yeah wait do you have the you
don't have the car yet
oh so I still need a card yeah
do you know where I get it yeah kind of
go on
you don't have it right now I wouldn't I
just got to do the manhole stuff first
so I gotta kill some dogs no I
is this the kennel is back through the
parking garage door first oh there's a
man hold down this hallway okay which
manhole should i do first try this one
out but also their dogs just say no in
here no a little further down that's
locked yeah I think there
but yep because I took that plant
remember mm-hmm and you were like don't
do that but I did it yeah you got it
where are they they're gonna make me
turn the corner let's look at my
schematics here all right cool so if I
just turn left he'll be there yeah
somewhere should I switch to my shotgun
if there's just one pistol old knock it
back just don't [ __ ] it up
show yourself
no [ __ ] I'm cat-sitting a one-eyed cat
and when he peeks around corners he only
it's like put his face barely around it
depending on which corners go around its
Pete Browns cat you know that cat super
cute oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] there's another one too yes run run
and get better what I thought you saw it
yeah reset it reset it go you go
I thought you saw it didn't see it okay
yeah probably best to lure them out come
back to my way to shock on them right
now pistols fine lure them out and then
what now and then go back down this
hallway they jump behind me well yeah
yeah there you go sweet perfect shoot
yeah I keep shooting nice nice shoot
yeah yeah this is going really well
not too well yeah yeah
Oh No
okay shut up shut up nice
damn he's thinking a lot unless there
should be it I went well I'm glad that
reset didn't reset like how cool is that
dad dancing on Your Grave this game
makes me hate dogs
like the movie greenroom does I love
dogs and I hate dogs dogs the manhole
lid is open there you go you mean their
ego I didn't need it for the kennel won
you do well it's I still wouldn't
recommend going down here yet
anyway yeah why cuz of all the dogs
skanks Clank prank shake skank I did
sorry it's not a sound effect okay so
should I go through that door or should
I go through the ladder
yeah come through that door okay why are
you laughing when you say that I don't
know no reason
oh my god it's a safe no no but like I'm
just remembering the safe room is here
you could have just gone here last time
it would've made too much a different
speed I think we just want to end the
episode and I don't know if you wanted
to fight two dogs alright cool so now
what oh no you should yeah you're good I
just saved not saving I'm not saving I
can do this alright so should I go
through the other man home oh that's a
wall
oh yeah so okay we have to save room
down here which would have been nice I
don't know if we okay we can use it
again later yeah you need a manhole
opener for the kennel the kennel has
three how many dogs are in there but I'd
like to know because I'm on caution and
I could die pretty quickly if I don't
get out so I need to up the ammo on
McGann C otherwise known as reloading no
that's not what I say you just set up
the ammo and my gun that's yeah don't
speak for me that's what I meant
I'm gonna up the ammo on my gun okay I'm
gonna add to it with more ammo I'll show
you come back you totally did you stop
the ammo on your gun that's it it's like
you loaded it again we explore this
garage a little bit okay
well oh you mean just the area mm-hmm
plant can I have it okay good orange I
mean you might want to use a semi
soonish at some point in the mixed herbs
maybe if you get one once more but you
should be fine I just know I'm gonna get
hit by a dog get your shotgun ready
mommy you don't necessarily have to do
it so good
nah dude I mean you don't you don't need
your shotgun what for this part I'm just
saying if it makes you feel safer go for
it you have a decent ma shells it's just
depends on how many dogs there are you
have to keep me in front of you that I
can't go game loves to not let you do
that or to [ __ ] me because I turn really
slowly yeah there's nothing in here
kennel entrances okay yeah sell engines
would been okay so this is the kennel
bends no no all right I have concern in
the humming all right you ready no are
they in their cages because if I could
shoot them in their cages that'd be
ideal very nice yeah don't even shoot up
there Nicky wait you don't shoot
I wasted a couple bullets I don't like
that angle
none of these are great here's little
pity patty feeties what should I do
he's not gonna come over here so I heard
him he growled he's growling [ __ ] this
sucks
how many are there oh no there's
multiple angles I'd like to think about
this
oh that's horseshit could I just go
through the manhole he's I'm I would
recommend going to the manhole and
turning around or something like similar
but why cuz you think there's one by the
manhole no guarding the manhole [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry I just panicked he would have seen
you if you're by now sick animation okay
you can go check this way go to your
math quick so it's red there's stuff in
here you feel like checking it out well
I just gotta kill that dog that's all
yeah I'll do it do it if you think I'm
afraid to kill dogs that's not the
problem
keep going he could be anywhere where
are you you're not you oh my god oh wait
I just filled up all my slots mm-hmm you
can even combine those and you wanted
you left you left oh yeah that's really
smart
bounnam you're so safe for a second
right you know he's gonna hit me before
we're gonna get hit Oh use one of those
mixer for sure
well should I use it after he hits me no
use right now cuz I don't it's not like
guaranteed it's gonna do the same exact
yeah use it they got another one
Oh chucka oh my god it takes me so long
to turn around
you might be turned around enough
already to shock on them I would
[ __ ] you yeah okay timed as well oh I
didn't do it
oh wait should I didn't okay we're good
maybe I could shoot them while they're
on the ground that wasn't worth it I'm
still on caution that went really bad
how do they both that blue Zephyr poison
yeah
should I take it yeah yeah yeah hope to
have on hand why I'm out to do poison
stuff in general yeah I can't believe
one caught caution already there's a
blue robe over near Ben that we didn't
get either I might be worth getting on
the way back just in case all right
going down one downtown
damn it those [ __ ] dogs
hate dogs no no no and you could just
run where okay so straight right right
letter okay what
[ __ ] you shotgun run run run run yeah
yeah you can stare i rerouted that car
so feller oh my god you didn't tell me
you had confidence she was like blocking
my way
gram I may need a new place mm-hmm
ever been here before just yeah I've
never been here nope okay so should I go
here into storage [ __ ] spider second
spider really tripped me up
oh those blue from there
now do the spiders poison me into yeah
they can okay I mean other things can
too but it's mainly a snake for the
biggest concern in the first game
do I need any new items like I'm still
got these these plugs and I got this
valve handle
I could combine these green plans with
those blue ones I got a lot of options
here I'm bring one green herb and then
ask for that we good for now
did the spiders even hit me I don't
think they did no I think I got away all
right I'm going in here the sick door
remember the door where zombies came
through you screwed me over so much I
don't trust you anymore Fela can you
develop no way ah no I don't think yet
not yet it doesn't like a valve room
though yeah based on my powers of
perception I feel like this is a valve
room hmm looks like a panel to release
the lock the there are descriptions okay
you know what's right nearby King plug
insertion rook plug insertion Bishop
plug insertion nightclub I'm missing us
another night plug yeah do you know
where they go
well I feel like that's what we got to
do this episode I mean I need that I
need that was my fault for bleeding all
this way without that it's true it is
your fault whatever I'm having fun like
remembering this game now I don't
haven't played as much to remaster well
as long as you're happy I'm about to go
through god damn spider town again
Oh Aida my name is Leon I'm with the RPD
it's a dead end
you think we can get upstairs through
this shaft mmm give me a boost
I'll go and check I was gonna make a
shaft joke but I said nothing
oh my god I made a wand
my name is ADA
oh don't look at me I'm a - I love with
every boy
check out her photo with her and John up
there if you want I would love to not
it's not very good photo well great I
got health now cesspool ain't as a
cesspool now no 8 is gonna get me that
plug I hear dog [ __ ] you
oh man I'm getting really good at dogs
how many dogs are out here handguns not
as effective as Leon's I have like one
of those wiener guns that girls used to
put in there like in like the old
westerns the pea shooters panty hose yes
the ones that I put my guide about want
a guy got to pay VAT mister hey there
mister this is uh this is this year's a
piano bar not up not up amusement park
wait not about second go on goes out
amusement parks men can touch women as
much as they want Park is this is a I'm
a lady and I shoot dogs just something I
do
sure like I'd give a [ __ ]
what you didn't want to do that yet
drainin then kind of rearrange them
before you fill it I see can ADIS whim
no I don't think like this game knew how
to make that happen
are there spiders down here she can hop
gracefully down though can you see me
free claw the corner your eye yeah but I
don't do they up uh might be too late
get down dum-dum there's a puzzle like
this in ocarina of time kind of like a
bad one
yeah that's not it's in the in Lon Lon
ranch that the hay silo in the back I'll
a fees for the aha moment not the box
pushing yeah
I like don't care for puzzles in which
che deliver the box pushing she that is
her John used to push box all the time
well that makes up for me not saying the
shaft joke earlier yeah Kofi uni window
every chance I get not that I meant to
it just came out that way what if an
alligator fellow is healing well I would
just walk across these boxes
it would have no impact at all it's
interesting because there was a box
puzzle in the other game in Resident
Evil 1 mm-hmm
yeah no I thought it was hey the night
plug thought it was the night bug day
plug Club here all that was it's getting
smaller where is it what's happening a
shrink-ray get some [ __ ] for the own oh
I should increase can I give those to my
new boyfriend Leon John would be rolling
in his grave if he knew what you just
said
wait that's it that's it for now oh no
check your map or something see well
look like what am i clairvoyant what I
play this game before you only need one
of those yeah I just making a stronger
point I see that water's very still
oh yeah more like jello feel like they
didn't think that through as part of
Leon's party and this really remote part
of the police station they made a jello
pool looks like your party's been
canceled somebody made jello shots not
air supply the water tank with jello so
you could swim in it Leon can you hear
me ADA I've been sitting here for two
hours hand on my hip leaning right you
do that's how they stand what she
accidentally throws a grenade instead of
a key Wow hey I start stealing pieces of
clothing I'll catch up with you later
what ada wait I I didn't hear you nope
so that's probably how I get the final
plug Hey
mm-hmm okay you tricked me should I
shock on these fighters cause I feel
like I got lucky last time you know I
mean if you got that happened last time
might not might as well just save the
shells do it again next time and if it
does doesn't work you can play you're
talking about you know just roll with
what's happening
oh [ __ ] okay no you're good you're fine
there's a savior man okay yeah there you
go idiot what an idiot
go unpause in yourself should we mix the
blue with a green no I think you're only
on I think I was on caution because the
because of these fears you might as well
do it sooner than later
like right now I don't have a blue on me
I put them in the yeah no I mean save
room saving wrap here same the night
save my name saved my again save my game
oh wait isn't it no wait
confused again where's the save room oh
you [ __ ] I went past it he did which
one's faster to go to isn't there to
save rooms and listen to get to the
closest one you have to go past the
spiders again I thought there was one in
this area there was but it was back
before the spiders it was the other
eight a long door that was before I was
poisoned
I don't want to do that wash away what's
the door at the end of the hall that's
the parking garage and the cell I
thought there was another save room you
know that's the parking garage damn it
it's at the end of this that's the cell
that's been so it there was a save room
but it's past the spider so I think that
your best bet is to go probably to the
other I mean if you're confident gonna
pass the spiders again you could do that
no I'm not
yeah I go into this main room yeah if
there's a parking garage you should have
enough time to get to the other manhole
yeah it's not that far right
it's here right oh my god yeah through
here then go to the other manhole I'll
be fine I'm totally gonna get this yeah
you also have but yeah you might as well
stay down your G have a club door you
can open down here cool cool cool we're
in agreement
- I really hope you don't die in the way
you have a green herb right now
[ __ ] yeah you think you know what [ __ ]
[ __ ] you might am I gonna die
mmm what makes you you just went down in
health oh because of my limp II try to
think you shouldn't use those mixed
herbs or a green herb
use those mixed herbs I'd say dad how
bad it is
yeah you're in like a danger right now
there you go keep please keep running Oh
keep sprinting that's unfortunate that
swai did use the mixer
no you watch you fart oh no you're good
you're gonna keep running down the end
the hallway I thought it was right
you got you're fine do i you [ __ ] you
want use that green one no no you're
fine just keep sprinting in the hallway
and I take a left right I forgot there
were there always two in here no there
weren't any in there yet dude oh God use
that green herb you are so close to
dying with that poison Bailey yeah use
that now please oh my god yeah okay now
go fast another liquor here shut up
there's another leg around the corner
stop it I did it I have been a death's
door like this entire time yeah it's
tense right there that's the same room
oh right where the spiders there all
right this is where you come back when
the [ __ ] to lickers
Oh God heal up you're gonna be danger I
think almost all right um should you a
save now I kind of do
we haven't it hasn't been going safe you
got some ribbons coming up so much I
have no idea oh my god I think it's been
like it's been at least half an hour
yeah save
you did a decent amount there your you
got the cookie you got did the ADA thing
I don't kill a bunch of dogs you dodged
some spiders that's good
I didn't dodge my way there you didn't
buy everything this game like my dodging
has been really bad controls get used to
it your first time it's good all right
what am i doing I need to put these [ __ ]
away at least I have this club card key
yeah
but because I'm almost dead I think we
should end it there and then we will use
this club next episode cool ok few doors
you can use yeah all right I feel pretty
good about that thank you guys for
watching we are going to continue to
survive I'm so close to death constantly
knocking at death's door here worst case
scenario we can reload an earlier save
Oh God
alright thank you guys I will see you
guys again next week for another couple
episodes of Resident Knievel